and my dad died when I was 16. oh man so
did mine when you're 16. yeah really
yeah he had cancer [ __ ] man my dad fell
in the ice it hit his head while walking
my dog my dad was way older though my
dad was born in 1933.
in Switzerland was he really yeah dude
my dad was born in
1910 or 1912. damn in Nicaragua wow
damn we got a similar situation but yeah
so my my grandparents Rudolph and Varina
are from like 1880 or something yeah my
dad was born in 1933 my mom born in like
56 and yeah 23 year difference and I uh
and here I am man I like to have an
older parents I liked it yeah well I
think it'd probably add some sort of a
worldliness to you and as well like
things you know you don't even recognize
that
um
and you have to also I think I realized
I was thinking about this the other day
you're watching an older person so then
how you interact with the world and how
you interact with things is probably
going to be a little bit different than
if you have like a a capable and you
know constantly on the go father whereas
if you have someone that's probably just
um even just spending more time at peace
or relaxing or just sitting there my dad
would just sleep all the time and his
eyes would start leaking and I didn't
know what was going on he was just old
you know people get older yeah
absolutely wait so how how old was he
when he passed
he was 86. 86 wow while he was 16. but
that's so wild man gosh what a dark
surprise your dad just went for a walk
who's had we were uh it was in the
middle of winter uh he slipped in my
eyes hit his head and like
didn't realize it till like five hours
later be like internal brain bleeding
you start having a bad reaction it's
[ __ ] up because I was at my mommy's
house we were like smoking and just
chilling and I got a call from my mom
like yo dad's in the hospital like and
you were stoned you should come I was
stoned and freak me out extra I mean
about the time I got there obviously I
suffered up but I was uh yeah it was a
really bad timing
um but I think overall it kind of helped
me
in life man like I I at least looking
back I'm proud of how I how I took it
you know I I it motivated me my mom kind
of shut down for a while and couldn't do
a lot because she was just like you hit
her so hard ah um so I kind of became
the man of the house when I was 16 and I
had to get myself into college and do
all this stuff
and I think it motivated me a lot man
like I miss my dad like like [ __ ] but
but I think that that was uh you know a
turning point for me
did you get to say anything to him when
you got to the hospital or he was
unconscious no it was it was bad timing
I think right when I got there he had
just like reached the point of like not
being able to talk anymore uh she was
like kind of like coffee and [ __ ] but
yeah yeah and obviously I said [ __ ] to
him I don't know maybe hopefully you
heard it
um
but yeah man that was I was 16. it was
January
uh
uh he's born in Switzerland I think I
said that and this was Citizen and
everything man I still see his family
sometimes he had don't so he had
uh five siblings grew up in a family of
six and every single one of them has
died in an accident except for the two
that are alive who are like 95 and 96.
damn so my family's just on some [ __ ]
yeah and you just hurt yourself yeah I
do I break my my [ __ ] all the time man
it's that extra two inches two inches
man I'm I'm a survive man I'm not gonna
die I think if I die if I make it to 50
I'm Gonna Be Happy
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one